okay
hi good afternoon everybody uh thank you
so much for joining us for this talk
my name is foreign i'm the manager of
the yale quantum institute and the uh
the host of this series of non-technical
talk on science and humanities that are
co-sponsored by the frankly program in
the science and the humanities
this
this series is trying to combat science
phobia and foreign physics phobia too by
introducing other medium to to the field
and talking about two different topics
that has on the intersection of all them
so in the past we you can see some of
the slides behind me or on your screens
in the past we had talks about quantum
physics and music we had physics and
dance we had mathematical crochet and uh
today we are very excited to be joined
by uh stewart smith
uh to talk about
the hapless dreamers and so in a very
exciting talk about uh digital arts uh
augmented reality and quantum simulators
so we started the series in 2017
and uh this is our 14th event of the
series so to give you a bit of
introduction to uh to swirl smith
so he's a digital artist and an ar
technologist
he has worked at a very well renowned
hybrid studio like the google creative
lab and the delta of the data art team
and funded more technology and strategy
consultancy
and he's also currently the head head of
customer of consumer augmented reality
at unity the gem engine
and so he received his mfa from
yellow university in graphic design and
the uh and his hard work artwork has
been exhibited in the
the museum of modern art in new york at
the zkm in germany at the sf moma in san
francisco and is part of the permanent
collection at the foundation cartier in
paris
if all of that wasn't enough on the side
he uh taught himself how to code and uh
he created and maintain the uh the
brother-based quantum security uh
simulator uh qgs uh so we'll talk a bit
about that so i think that's something
that will be very exciting for the
quantum crowds
uh so the talk will last about 50
minutes and then you will have time for
questions uh for the people on zoom over
there there's a feature at the bottom of
your screen are called q a so feel free
to type your question in and then we'll
take them as they pop in
please help me welcome uh swirl smith
and thank you for being here thank you
hi
uh as florian said i'm stuart smith
my background is an art code and graphic
design
but i think it's also important to try
to find the fun in making things
uh i do have a hard time describing what
i mean by that and so what i want to do
is step through some more visual
examples and maybe those examples will
promote some discussion some arguments
some debate uh and and hopefully just
describe what it is that i did
um i'll give you a little overview of a
few things and then i'll go deep on
about four projects so here's a little
overview uh i've made music videos using
vintage computers which is
a strange thing to do but i'd say quite
fun
um games that are played with windows
instead of within windows so a version
of pong for the browser that actually
uses pop-up windows to play
um very large panoramic data animations
that take up entire rooms so you can
walk into this animated data that's all
around you
i've even crafted
software synthesizers this runs right in
any web browser it's open source you can
even plug in a midi keyboard right in
your computer and you can play with it
and uh
with any luck let's just see if this
[Music]
so there you go you can try this out on
your own time and i'll turn the volume
down so we don't get a feedback loop
there
um
i also got involved with consumer
virtual reality when it was just
beginning to take off
so around that time i wrote the vr
controller for a 3d library called 3js
provided an easy generic way for
web-based vr apps to support a bunch of
different hand controllers because you
don't want to worry about supporting uh
you know like a gear vr controller and
daydream control you want to worry about
your game right or whatever experience
you're making so this made it a lot
easier to focus on the fun parts
and uh i took care of the heartbeats for
you
over at the google data arts team we
used my vr controller library to power
this vr music video for the band lcd
sound system
and i'm going to talk a little more
about that in a bit
you could dance along to the song in vr
and a recording of your dance would then
become part of the video itself
so each one of these uh you know cone
people with the little baton hands
is someone who danced to the song and
had their dance recorded and then
incorporated into this video
and yeah you can see some people are
very enthusiastic about this
so i i also released space rocks which
was just a personal projects and not
affiliated with google or
you know really awesome bands or
anything
this was my personal tribute to atari's
1979 classic asteroids uh button vr of
course
and uh i took my vr controller library
and i added something i called
multi-channel haptic feedback
which made it super easy to add complex
haptic commands to your uh vr apps
so like if you need to feel kickback in
the controller from firing your laser
but there's also like the hum of the
engine uh revving up and down
that's really complicated uh this
multi-channel haptic feedback thing made
it very easy to just describe and code
uh succinctly what you want and it takes
care of the rest so
that was a lot of fun of course
um a few years later oculus upped the
game by adding hand tracking uh support
for web-based virtual reality and i
immediately wrote this handy js library
you'll notice uh js is a big theme i
love browser-based stuff and javascript
so
uh you'll see that pop up a lot
um so what this does is it makes
recording and then recognizing hand
poses on the fly really quick and easy
to do
so instead of just pinch gestures to
like select things
you can recognize tons of shapes uh you
know including the whole asl finger
spelling alphabet finger guns is the
most fun uh you ever as a child just
pretend you could shoot lasers out of
your fingers uh
that may sound childish but come on it's
fun
i made it possible so there you go
you made you made it possible for us to
imagine that
that was a thing that was a bit of a
stretch yeah that was a bit of a
i didn't think anyone would call me on
it but i'm glad you're keeping me honest
why work on lasers if you figure out how
you do it with your fingers i'd really
like to know how
so would i that would be fun
um so i've made a lot of work outside
the r2 um
i started coding when i was quite young
but i'm educated as a graphic designer
and artist
i didn't study computer science
i've worked well i guess you covered
this i've been a commissioned artist uh
lucky enough to have some work in
different galleries and museums
i'm also a lifelong mediocre to terrible
musicians so you'll see music pop up a
lot in the stuff i do
and i even enjoy writing essays
occasionally despite having no lessons
to do that uh
i think my my friends who are actually
gifted in that medium cringe when they
read what i've written but it's still
it's fun to write
it's fun to communicate with people
um speaking of which uh and
cringe-worthy things i i started to
become aware of design as a kid
um i had started this low-budget
magazine as a teenager or a zine as a
kid say
basically as a ruse as a hack uh this is
a way that i could meet and interview
some of my favorite bands and their
record labels would like send me the
music for free
pre-digital streaming um but that was
that was pretty amazing i don't know if
you've ever tried to meet a band after a
show they purposely make it impossible
but if you can touch with the publicist
and say well i don't even really want to
meet the band i just you know i have
this assignment i have to interview them
they're like oh well right this way
and you get to meet everyone
and they will send you all of the
ephemera and music and albums and things
that's great
so i would uh i do that and then i'd
also interview
uh musicians about the heavy
political topics of the day
so that was a way to combine
an interest in music and politics and
all of this meant that i
this graphic design is terrible this is
teenage graphic design
but what it exposed me to is i had to
start thinking about visual hierarchy
and typography you know the interplay of
text and image so even though this was
terrible it planted good seeds
scenes that i would later follow all the
way here
to yale so i received my mfa and graphic
design just a few blocks over
um
somehow somehow i squeaked through
and after yale i moved to europe for a
while i became an artist in residence at
zkm or zacchaeum as
i said
that's the center for art and media
technology in khalsa germany uh in
southern germany beautiful
beautiful place uh
folks there might say that it's very
boring i thought it was quiet and lovely
and a really good place to get work done
uh eventually i moved back to the u.s
and joined google's creative lab in new
york
uh which is sort of a subversive
marketing department now that i think
about it uh
and later i jumped to google's data arts
team to do some uh more music video work
so
i've also spent some time at various
other large tech companies doing
whatever large tech companies do
and i'm currently head of consumer
augmented reality at unity and everyone
knows unity right have you heard it yeah
yeah so our game engine is all about
making real-time 3d rendering for the
masses
70 of the world's games are made with
unity
and we're not just 70 of uh sorry 70 of
mobile should definitely make sure i get
that right we're not just 70 of mobile
games we're 50 of all games so if you
play games you've played something big
with you
uh so like i said that's meaning you're
the drive software so i'm the person
that has no idea
unity is a way
to uh make game development much easier
and distribution so you could make your
game once in the unity editor and then
you can say i want to launch it for
windows i want to launch it for mac i
want to you know put it on vr headsets
and whatnot and uh
while there's still pain points and the
development of complicated software
unity helps grease those wheels and make
it much easier to do
does it have its own problem in language
or it just uses existing um
unity is primarily c sharp focus so
if you're familiar with c sharp or java
c c plus plus uh any of those things
will translate nicely
into unity stuff
um happy to talk more about unity too
after all this if you want to talk about
that
but i want to show you four things that
i think are kind of different from each
other and i'll give you a sense of
how i think about this stuff
so the first one is a project called
racer
this came out of google creative lab
google's chrome team was enjoying this
big market share for desktop
so
google was very happy uh however chrome
on mobile was not so popular i think
just people weren't really aware of it
and uh
so the google chrome team asked us
uh to make an ad campaign
typical typical marketing ask like let's
do uh maybe some tv spots posters in the
subway stuff like that and we said no
we said we have a better idea uh
we were starting to obsess over racing
games and slot car racing games in
particular
and i started brainstorming
uh
just random ideas about tracks made of
software that could change on the fly
that were modular
and i also created some quirky crash
demos that were you know inspired by
early vector games like asteroids and
tempest and whatnot
and we also had this idea about racing
across screens so you literally needed
to have multiple phones or tablets or
what have you next to each other
it was taking this idea of social gaming
and and pushing you physically together
this was obviously pretty pandemic
it'd be it'd be a little strange to uh
push that today and so this was the
final result we said no
posters in the subway uh you know no tv
spots
let's make this game that shows off how
powerful chrome for mobile really is so
you don't just say we can show you
and we can make it fun so you actually
want to be shown
uh
our racing game needed a soundtrack
and we actually convinced this guy
giorgio marooter to score the soundtrack
and he wrote individual tracks for each
phone so one phone would be playing the
percussion one would have like the lead
melody and so on
and
if you're not familiar with giorgio uh
he's an electronic disco legend and uh
he's collaborated with daft punk more
recently
and uh yeah he's he's a legend in the
community i can't believe i still can't
believe we got him to do this
so those were all the ingredients for
this game and here's what that
experience looked like
[Music]
[Music]
so i think you can see how you need to
uh hug the track
i should have should have maybe
explained beforehand if you're not
familiar with slot cars the whole idea
is that you don't get to steer you just
have one big dumb gas pedal and you need
to go as fast as you possibly can on the
straightaways and then let up when you
hit the curbs otherwise you spin off the
track and so
we replicated that behavior here where
you know your your beautiful uh flagship
multi-touch device
was just used as one big dumb button
which we thought there was some humor in
that
um
so uh sundar pichai who's now google ceo
uh he unveiled racer at google i o that
year
and the tech press loved it
and so that that's kind of what we were
aiming for was this recognition in the
tech community and then also in the
broader community people just playing
the game for fun
but we also struck a chord with the
music press as well which we didn't
really expect and that was awesome uh
people were really getting on to the
fact that giorgio maroon
aside from death punk he had come out of
retirement for us to do this
uh off the record we made a limited
vinyl run pressing of the soundtrack and
giorgio even signed our
our copies so
that was pretty great
um this was a fun project on its own but
as a nice bonus we were awarded the cad
line goal for creativity and innovation
on mobile devices
you probably don't know what that is
because it's a silly industry award for
like marketing um but it's it just means
people thought it was cool
that made us happy too
so sadly racer is no longer live i think
some of the website still exists but
it'll say something like your network is
too slow
which is just a fake error code for you
know we were only going to support this
for about 12 months anyway it's a
marketing campaign
now it's it's off the radar otherwise
i'd race you all we could have a
competition up here
um all right
next project auto compose uh
this is a much less visual uh project
and i think it demonstrates a
predilection for combining interest in
product design marketing and and also
cutting edge research just kind of
blending all of these interests together
so
uh back in 2013
i had more or less accidentally followed
google x google star marissa meyer to
yahoo
and the narrative there was that marissa
would rescue this once great company uh
that at this point was falling apart
and yahumah in particular was in need of
rescuing
so we got this official ask from the
yahoo mail team from the product team
they wanted a valentine's themed
marketing campaign
uh
and i guess that just came to mind
because it was late january and they're
like what's a reason to promote
something
uh regardless of the reasoning they gave
us this ask near the end of january
which meant we had about three weeks
until valentine's day
and also because we needed to put all
these plans in motion and in a
production ahead of valentine's day we
really had about two weeks
so
it's kind of a nightmare scenario uh
when
someone comes to you and says uh two
weeks from now we need to have something
that changes the narrative around yahoo
mail from everyone being upset to people
saying oh isn't that a nice product
so i had an idea for this
uh it's an idea that i played with a few
years prior during the height of the eye
something craze
so
think imac itunes i life and the crown
jewel at the time the ipod
iphone and ipad were still super secret
some skunk works projects that you know
no one knew about
uh
and that idea was i quit i apologize for
the
the language uh this was a resignation
letter generator
so your job your relationship your
friends get out of anything instantly
with i quit
this is a real
that's useful right this is a real
functioning website that i launched uh
you put in the email address of who you
want to quit
and it would do the rest uh it would
generate a random formal letter of
resignation and send it to them
yes very very useful uh the faux
testimonials i had on the website were
absurd
uh you know uh
i used to do corporate advertising until
i realized having a soul is nice i fired
up i quit bam now i can starve with
pride you know it's just
it's kind of ridiculous uh
faux testimonials uh here's an actual
sample email
that it generated automatically on the
fly
uh
this email serves as my formal letter of
resignation effective immediately it's
not my intention to injure feelings with
this letter but to merely illuminate a
path toward a more functional
environment for myself and and it goes
it's
ridiculous right
did you write all this
the way that i made this original
version is i had a list of opening lines
tons of uh you know middling lines
and then a few choice closers
and it would randomly assemble
those and
i'm glad you asked about that because
that's the seeds of
of what we're about to talk about
uh so that's when it hit me this
valentine's day campaign
uh
writing love letters is hard
all right dear jane you are so
neat
um it's a pain right uh so i quickly
taking that sort of humor i coded this
demo
that constructed love letters
automatically right in the yahoo mail
compose window
and if you didn't like the result you
could just edit it yourself or click the
auto compose button again for a new
composition
so you can see it just
cycling through you click and then
and it gives you these things
i i also created this interface for our
copywriters uh so they could craft their
lines and test them this is really this
is like a showcase for a good copywriter
right because it's all about the
language that goes in there it's really
all about the text and i feel like you
rarely get to do that in
in a tech marketing medium but
but here it is so uh
i wrote the pseudo programming language
so literally they could just write
opener have a whole list of openers and
then you know other there's like mad lib
style replacements and things that it
could do as well
and it would automatically uh take what
you've done in here and use it as the
contents for
what was being generated
in this way they could test
if their lines really work together
sometimes a brilliant line of text seems
like it could flow into another and then
you see them juxtaposed and
the language doesn't feel right
so this was a way that they could get
check a bunch of compositions
and also it was
really important to me that the number
of permutations possible exceeded the
number of
daily active users
so that in theory
every single person using yahoo mail
could generate a love letter and every
one of them would be unique so
so it was a lot
and
we launched it in time for valentine's
day and it was a success
we were able to change the conversation
around yahoo mail from
hate at the time to uh something
uh a bit more amused people were at
least smiling and sharing this
so uh
yeah the sentiment was was positive for
a while
so because autocompose was a hit we
immediately started looking for ways to
take it even further
and you had asked about how it was
constructed and it was just lines of
text and they were randomly assembled
together
that that was good for a two-week
project but to really go further we
needed actual machine learning right and
thankfully right around that time yahoo
had purchased this startup called
sunlight and what it did was
automatically summarize long news
articles into very short snippets
so i was able to
take these ideas together
and sketch that in out into a patent for
using existing emails as training data
for constructing new email drafts
so you have an email uh you know corpus
of all of your missives to uh you know
friends
your mom or whatever and the way that
you interact with different people will
be different if you're emailing a
professor i would imagine you don't
speak in the same way that you might
speak with some of your friends uh there
may be a bit of more formality or what
have you or maybe not i don't know i
don't know your professors individually
but the point was that we could
use machine learning to look at those
correspondences and then
predict or imagine what another
correspondence would be between you and
that recipient so uh
you know let's say you have the flu and
you need to find a way to apologize to
your buddies for missing an important
birthday
uh if you're really feeling sick do you
want to write that email or just let the
computer write it for you and
apologize uh
you know i'm skeptical about whether we
want any of this stuff
but but it was fun to to work on um well
you're certainly making everybody lazier
a few years later google did the same
thing uh and instead of auto compose
they called it smart reply
so i'm not saying i invented smart reply
but
maybe it was just in the air at the time
i like to float that and pretend i'm
more important than i am
uh anyway i wrote about all of this in
an essay called the charm offensive so
if you're curious to know more
uh semi-humorous essay about how this
came to be okay uh sorry second and last
one here called dance
tonight so uh virtual reality has become
a big part of my life for the past few
years
and the first vr system that i ever
tried was a five dev kit
and uh once i tried it i knew
immediately i wanted to make stuff for
vr
um but i'm a web guy so uh i had to find
other people who were building web-based
vr tools and this was in
the very early days of this stuff and i
started making little demos like this
where you'd be in this weird rippling
environment of this kind of dream sand
substance that would swirl together to
make objects and
i don't know i thought it was very
artistic at the time and now i'm like oh
it's a decent tech demo i guess but
these were these were the early days
um i also built some early co-presence
demos and again all this stuff was
running in the browser
uh one day i got about 80
folks in google creative lab to join me
in this little vr universe
so everyone was this these sort of peg
people and they could look around and
everyone would have this randomly
generated
name that was a random color and a
random animal
and uh you could run around like little
mario characters and teleport between
worlds but that was about it that was
about the extent of the interaction
but for late 2015
not bad
that was a technical feat
i created this day and night web app for
my kids uh their grandparents live in
europe and i wanted to give them a
better understanding of how time zones
work
so here uh they can float in space you
put the headset on and you're in outer
space above this rotating earth and the
city lights come on as you know night
falls and you know you can get a sense
of how it is the middle of the day in
one spot in the middle of the night in
another
uh in a very visual visceral sense
uh so this universe is movable and
scalable
i was making something for my kids who
are obviously a little shorter than i am
so the whole idea was that you could
grab the world
as if you were going to do pinch and
zoom like on your phone and you could
expand the universe or contract
contracted and rotated put it wherever
it was comfortable
so you could have the earth
kind of about this size just floating
here
and that's fun or you could make it huge
and you know you could be kind of
floating right next to the curvature of
the earth and it shifts between day and
night
um
this was a uh another thing that i was
working on that does not seem to flow so
smoothly
when we're trying to mirror screens here
but this was a giant data visualization
of flight patterns
and i ported this to vr and you could do
the same thing you could expand it you
could actually sit inside the earth and
look out and see
well here if we're not over the ocean
there's a bit more to look at
uh you could actually see all of this
stuff swirling around you which was
viscerally uh
a lot of fun
and uh so
i was working on this vr stuff while i
was at creative lab and then i moved
over to the data arts team which is
another team within google and this is
the first thing that i put into motion
over there
uh i won't dwell too much on it since i
mentioned it earlier but it was just a
way to make working with vr controllers
easier
and uh but i'm happy to dwell again on
asteroids because i love that game so
here it is translated into vr
or if we go back for a moment the
original asteroids is a
black and white vector uh game
and that's because of the hardware it
was built to run on a vectrex screen so
speaking of lasers
well i guess would you consider that a
real laser or
yeah
yeah
i like to think of it as a laser but i i
realize that's just because it sounds
cooler but it's not a real uh yeah
anyway uh photon gun electron gun that's
a word
gun is different yeah yeah
um
so that's why it looks this way and i
wanted to translate it to vr and at
first i was tempted to
make something that looked like this but
i realized conceptually i should
probably be doing what the hardware
wants and in a way that's truer to the
original game
and so that's why it ends up being these
uh you know flat surfaces
uh with shading to indicate their their
depth and
where they are in space
so with all of those little vr pieces in
my palette uh and now with the data arts
team that's when uh i made and when i
say i mean we the team may dance tonight
and it's a ever-changing dance
collaboration between lcd sound system
and their fans in virtual
reality so uh when you load it up you
get this little tutorial
uh this ball represents the camera it
enters the room and the room lights up
and that means it's time to dance and
each room
represents about eight seconds of music
that's the uh the amount of time it
takes for the phrasing the music to turn
around
so uh you record your dance
and then you can actually record
multiple dances
so it could just be you doing this but
you could build up i think yeah 20
copies of yourself if you want to so you
can start to make more complex movements
and things uh
even if you're just on your lonesome so
here's what it looks like from the
inside which is a little chaotic because
this is someone actually dancing
and uh
let's see if i can do this with sound
without feedback
you can see the ball isn't falling
okay i will turn down the sound so i
don't so i don't get that feedback so
this way i can talk through something
like each one of these people is
selectable
so uh let's say i'll grab one of these
folks over here
and when i click on them this is their
point of view camera so you can relive
that dance experience
um which may make you sick since
it's this added motion you can also
let's see where the ball is
you can also grab the ball
and this is a little more of a steady
cam experience so you are now the ball
floating through here and if you do this
in a vr headset you don't just have the
straight ahead view you can just look
around and it's like you're on this slow
moving carriage and
you know you can see what's happening
everywhere else
let's see if i can jump on the timeline
here
it goes on to this other part of the
universe where you're no longer
constrained to these rooms
and you can see all these other folks
dancing and reacting to the music
and
i think you get the general idea
for this video
so uh we launched it
at google i o again and uh we had this
big party you can see all of this
ridiculous uh we actually built rooms
physical rooms that correspond to those
virtual rooms so you have this trippy
experience uh
where you
step into the physical room put on the
headset you're in the virtual room
and uh also people are in a ball pit
which seems like it should not be real
but that was physical
kids as adults you could write books
about that
um
and here's yeah just a bit more of uh
overview this i'm not making fun of this
guy by having him here he's actually a
very uh well-known well-respected vr
journalist and i'm so excited
i'll take it can i can i do the room
so uh that was a lot of fun and a fun
way to launch the project as well
all right so this is my fourth and final
project to show
since this is for yqi i should probably
talk about something quantum related
maybe
but before i i do i want to make
something clear first
let's say that this circle represents
quantum physics uh this is all the
knowledge about how the universe
actually conducts itself right photons
locality thermodynamics packets of light
whatever whatever you want to talk about
and over here is quantum computing and
this is pure math and logic and
you don't need to know so much about
electrons or superconducting to just
write computer programs
and of course you have that intersection
the actual quantum hardware quantum
computers themselves
but this is the realm that i'm more
comfortable speaking about because i am
not a physicist i'm not an engineer and
if we're being totally honest uh my
personal knowledge scape looks a little
more like this
random puddles of knowledge even even
this is generous by the way
uh rather than a vast ocean of knowledge
that i think many of you folks have
but also this because we humans are
beautifully messy nonsensical creatures
so with this disclaimer in mind
i can talk about some of my quantum
projects
so i'm the creator and maintainer of
quantum javascript or qjs for short
and i'm the founder of open quantum
cloud uh so what is this stuff exactly
well we can go deep on qjs for a second
it's actually a few things at once
it's this website and the corresponding
source code repository
it's this drag and drop circuit composer
interface in particular
it's a quantum circuit simulator because
this is just software right it's not
actual quantum hardware
it's the entire code library and its
corresponding api
it's some concept primers that are there
to help get folks like me up to speed on
quantum computing quickly you know folks
with no real physics background or
quantum background uh just casual coders
with some rusty high school math
uh it turns out that's all you need to
start making some fun mistakes and then
you can learn more as you go
and it's the documentation too for the
qjs api because what good is a library
if you don't know how to use it
and when you put all of this together
there's a small but growing community of
enthusiastic folks who have also fallen
in love with this ridiculous idea of
using quantum and web browsers
because javascript wasn't chaotic enough
on its own right we have any javascript
coders here know what i'm talking about
no
really nerdy jokes uh i'm so sorry
uh so for this community i'm starting
something called o
q
c
uh the open quantum club and this is a
project i'm just spinning it up right
now
uh through a website that will feature
profiles and interviews with folks in
the quantum community
so the special focus here will be on the
humanity behind the map
since that's what i'm better at
obviously
so who are the personalities what are
the collective hopes and dreams and that
sort of thing
so stay tuned for more about that as we
head towards 2023
um
but let's talk about the oh yeah
interview project yes yeah and i've i've
conducted my first interview and i
forgot how difficult transcribing a long
interview can be so i need to finish
that and the website is partially
finished
so uh
it's in progress but not ready to launch
but yeah
mostly interview based
so this is the qjs website which is
really the hub for the whole qjs
experience
there are quantum tutorials the api
documentation all the things i just
mentioned
i'm going to play a quick demo video for
you that i made to show off some of the
features
okay all right quantum javascript it
starts off
with this
interactive circuit building interface
that runs right in your web browser and
i'll explain what these things are in a
moment but i'll just show you how it
operates first we can select everything
and throw it away and start over
we also have an undo button here which
is great and also a lock button so we
can
lock our circuit and
can't mess it up can't select things
can't throw stuff away
which is even more helpful on a mobile
interface
where there is no hover state and
selection you just you're tapping
uh perhaps you're tapping to scroll
perhaps you're tapping without meaning
to and you definitely don't want to mess
up a circuit that you've carefully
composed
but in this case we can throw down an
identity gate
and maybe a polyx gate and select them
and combine them together to make a a
controlled
uh gate here and
what we've just created here is a bell
state
and even if you don't understand any of
this stuff you can see
the live probability results
uh being updated in real time
as we change things
so it's really cool that you can drag
and drop stuff together
but you can also code things code
circuits
with javascript and what's even more
than that is you can combine the two so
if we open up our javascript console
here
let me clear it out
um it says that this circuit is except
uh accessible in our console
and so let's give that a shot let's see
we get a circuit back here let's make
this a little larger
let's see what that circuit looks like
we can get a diagram of it it's not very
interesting when we have a blank circuit
um but here we can
quickly build
that bell state again and you can see as
i'm editing the circuit we're getting
real
output
uh just like that
and here let me scroll up so we can
actually see
that this ascii diagram
looks very similar to what we have right
here doesn't it
and so that is pretty cool
and what's even cooler
is we can start to do things like
let's say we want to add another one of
those h gates right that's a hadamard
gate and we'll talk about that in a
second
let's add it to moment three
on wire 3
which should put it right there
let's see if we can do that oh and there
it is
so we can actually jump back and forth
between code and the drag and drop
interface
so it's not about um
dumbing something down not at all
uh with qjs you have access to this
quantum circuit both through code and
the drag and drop interface and you can
fluidly switch back and forth to
whatever
has least cognitive overhead in that
moment
uh let's say i need to get rid of
everything here in moment two
i could certainly code that or i could
just select it and throw it away right
so
i just want to emphasize that designing
a user interface and offering pictures
to look at and click on
is never about dumbing something down
it's about making tasks easier and more
efficient for us human beings who
require that
so uh qjs definitely sits on the
software side but i happen to work at
amazon for a while and amazon just so
happened to be working on a quantum
service called amazon bracket
you can access bracket for a prepared
jupiter notebook if you know what that
means
which is similar to other quantum
services quantum cloud services
so anyway here's a little demo video
that i made just a few months before
bracket launched publicly
using the qjs interface to drive it
so here i have a jupiter notebook
with amazon bracket loaded
which means that i can use python code
bracket is a python library
and i can use that to build quantum
circuits that i can then run on a
simulator in the cloud
or i can run on quantum hardware because
amazon has partnered with different
quantum hardware vendors
um and so
we can do that we can offer that uh to
our customers and that's pretty exciting
but what's also exciting is this
with just a few lines of html really two
lines of html
i can
inject
qjs
into this jupyter notebook it's now
injected and now
i can
inject my quantum circuit composer
and this composer which should look
awfully familiar
is writing
bracket code so this is actually bracket
python code
uh which right now is set to run on the
simulator in the cloud so that we can
get quicker results
um but if you wanted to you could switch
uh what device we're running on
and you could actually run this on
quantum hardware and get true quantum
results
so check this out
down here you can see where it says our
qjs circuit
equals a new circuit and it has a
placeholder identity gate
this is bracket code and we're about to
watch it change
as i start to compose stuff
look at that look how it put
a hadamard gate
and created a c naught gate
and we can take that and we can run that
what this is is a coin flip circuit
and we're waiting for the output to come
back from the cloud
so hadamard
puts the qubit into a state of
superposition
and then
this distributes
that superposition to
the qubit on the second register here
and so our two
possible outcomes are 0 0 and 1 1 and
you can see we've gotten a result back
from the simulator it's run that
simulation 100 times which is a
customizable
number
and it's come back roughly even 54 times
it came out zero zero and 46 times it
came out one one
so here's the deal
we can we can drag and drop and build
circuits as we please using the qjs drag
and drop interface
we can even edit that thing and get
real-time reports in the javascript
console still
and it is building amazon bracket code
which we can run on a simulator
or on actual quantum hardware
so that is pretty cool
so uh
that's it for quantum javascript um
question yeah for the out of bracket is
it a hardware quantum coming through
uh both so they have their own because
they have a huge cloud infrastructure
they have a pretty efficient simulator
that runs in the cloud but then they
partner with like uh riggetti and uh oh
gosh now the caffeine's wearing off but
they have a few different hardware
partners and so you can actually select
which system you want to use
um
all right maybe it's time to to wrap
this up
and uh that's me and the sorts of things
that i make i'm happy to take more
questions uh or if you're curious about
other work i'm happy to show more things
we can open it up a bit
why do we focus on the webpage
um well i guess there are two reasons
that i focus on web-based stuff uh one
is that's where i learn to code a lot of
things
because it's
you have access to the source code even
if it's not technically open source
everything that's happening on the front
end is there you can just view source in
the browser and start to pull it apart
you can
yes yeah things are a little more locked
down these days but you know there's
sort of the wild west days of uh you
know the late 90s early 2000s where
you know you could uh
take apart websites to a much greater
degree
uh so that that's how i learned to do a
lot of stuff uh the other reason is it's
so immediately shareable
and i think that's
pretty highly valued and everyone has a
web browser on their computer so you can
also
be sure that you can run things
and uh
yeah it's it's just a huge
i want to say market share and that's
the wrong word for it
it's a huge distribution channel
is there any limitation
can you do everything you want with the
browser do you have something
there are definitely limitations um
but there a lot of them are melting away
every day so for instance right now i'm
playing with a hardware accelerated
simulation
uh algorithm for pjs
because you have
uh through the web gpu api you can get
right onto the graphics card hardware
and use the hardware acceleration for
that
and in this case instead of making fancy
graphics uh i'm just you know
multiplying the large matrices of
quantum states
how did you get interested in computing
um oh well uh
i should probably have a real conceptual
answer for this but just for a long time
i thought quantum physics and quantum
mechanics sounded really cool
i was like wow that's neat and i kept
trying to wrap my head around it and i
couldn't
but
you know i keep watching like the pop
science explanations of what quantum is
which
you know once you start learning
anything about it you're like that's
stupid
um but then i came across a video by
this guy andrew heller i think is his
name from microsoft
and he gave a an internal microsoft
lecture that they published called
quantum computing for computer
scientists
which is him summarizing his favorite
book on the subject
and suddenly the way he was describing
it just as coding made a lot of sense
and i thought oh my god i bet i could
just write that and i bet i could write
it for the browser
and then start sharing it with folks and
that was
that was my
my first actual understanding of how
some quantum stuff works i would say i
still don't understand
any of it but uh
i could build a functioning simulator so
any other
questions uh
yeah yeah such a kind of follow-up so
why would someone use the web-based
application according to uh that's
desktop-based efficient
um
that's a good question but i'm not sure
there must be desktop applications but
uh
you know when i think about kiss kit or
uh
just the other things that i've seen
that are basically running in jupiter
notebooks those things are all web-based
even even if they're presenting
themselves as a native application under
the hood they're basically running
little web servers and
and the like
and it seems like that's okay because
what you really want to do
is you just want to have an
understandable interface to take your
thoughts and put them in a way the
computer can understand and then you're
going to push that to real quantum
hardware anyway so
the medium in between doesn't really
matter as much
and even with the simulation stuff
either you're simulating on the cloud so
it's just sending the instructions to
many computers to come back
uh or you're trying to do hardware
acceleration on your own local machine
and you can do all of that through a
browser so you don't necessarily need to
do that
okay
uh thank you very much uh for coming and
thank you for all your questions uh
let's thank us with me once more time
and then we'll see you all of us for the
public
event in the fall
thank you very much